ivan chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
yougoslave in sur la côte ouest de la
dalmatie central face à la botte
italienne se trouve trop dire
qu y puis ville romaine fort importante
un siècle avant jésus-christ
les fondations de cette cathédrale
datent de l'époque romane c'est à dire
du xiiie siècle
les sculptures du portail sans fil des
plus belles oeuvres du gosselaar le
portail encadré par deux lions puissant
du côté gauche monte f2 vous sur le dos
de la lionne qui tient dans ses griffes
un agneau et rasé du côté droit adam se
tient debout
le lion serrait dans ses griffes un
dragon ses statuts sont de grandeur
nature sur les colonies voisines on voit
des figures dessins ainsi que les
allégories des mois
et puis les signes du zodiaque
ce sont les maisons
l'autrichienne le palais de sinico qui
datent du casier
ce couvent et celui de saint nicolas
ces religieuses ne sortent jamais même
s'il leur arrivait de perdre la foi
elles sont cloîtrés pour la vie du jour
où elles ont choisi de l'être
il fut fondée en 1064 salona maintenant
ville antique la période de salona a
commencé vers 300 environ avec
l'empereur dioclétien kibati sont pas
les aspects après la sortie de celui de
nico médine et sarajevo ville souvent
détruites
hélas
la vieille ville vous retrouvez
l'artisanat presque moyenâgeux
et là comme en orient il ya énormément
de marché
et les keufs une pittoresque que l'on
croise au coin des rues posthume
pittoresque d'autrefois
le thé reja
il est remplacé
voici les bobos me ce sont des monuments
funéraires dans le parc de sarajevo
ils ont été élevés ici entre le 13e et
le xvème siècle ils ont également été
découverts en bosnie herzégovine arradi
méliès très exactement et il se trouve
en plein champ de qui sont-ils l'homme
ça l'histoire est à peu près muette
alain sujet les paysans persiste à leur
accorder une valeur sacrée avec un
pouvoir bénéfique
ils sont presque tous monolithique et
leur poids dépasse parfois de 30 tonnes
la décoration qui osent de difficile
problème d'interprétation
on présente des signes fondamentaux de
la vie le symbole du croissant de la
rosette du cercle de l'étoile sont des
manifestations du soleil et de la lune
cette voiture puis cette eau nous
conduit à ce petit village blotti d'une
façon charmante au milieu de la verdure
qui s'appellera digne et nous sommes
prêts de sto lat
les deux frères jardin vert et fenêtres
des maisons verrouillé il ya un petit
air secret ou charmant
qui n'aimerait vivre un moment derrière
se profile
ces chutes rafraîchissante
et maintenant mostar avec les minarets
blanc et son pont extraordinaire pour du
moyen-âge bien sûr regardé au changement
brutal
nous voici maintenant au monténégro ici
c'est aride
ici c'est rien
et d'une région extrêmement montagneuse
avec des lacs et les habitants de cette
région sont réputés pour leur fierté
oh
travailler par l'érosion est maintenant
une gousse là c'est l'instrument du
poète né guesh dont les cendres
voici le poète medef dont les cendres
reposent au sommet loftsson irène
chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de l'office de tourisme
yougoslave à paris et le concours de
saut lance péters montage pierre michel
rey sont jean-paul tic emploi script u7
andry illustration sonore dominique
valadié